>>> I JUST FEEL LIKE THE WHOLE
THING IS -- COME ON IN.
>> COME ON IN.
>> HEY.
WHAT'S UP, BOYS?
>> HEY, PETE IN THE HOUSE.
>> YO, PETE, MAN.
>> THE KING OF STATEN ISLAND,
HIMSELF.
>> WHAT?
>> NOTHING.
WHAT'S UP?
>> WELL, I JUST WANT TO SAY,
FIRST OFF, YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN
MAKING SOME REALLY FUN VIDEOS
FOR THE SHOW THIS YEAR.
>> DUDE.
>> THANK YOU, MAN.
>> THAT'S VERY NICE.
>> IT GOT ME THINKING.
I WAS LIKE, "WE SHOULD ALL DO A
VIDEO TOGETHER."
I HAVE THIS IDEA, WHERE MAYBE WE
CAN DO LIKE A MUSIC VIDEO ABOUT
HOW WE'RE ALL LIKE BEST FRIENDS
AND HOW WE'RE LIKE BOYS.
>> WE WOULD BE IN IT WITH YOU?
>> YEAH.
YOU WOULD BE THE BOYS, SO --
>> I WOULD SAY SO, YEAH.
>> YEAH.
>> LET'S DO IT.
>> I WOULD SAY SO, YEAH.
♪♪
>> LET'S DO IT.
>> YO.
♪♪
>> IT'S PETE AND PDD.
>> YO.
LET'S GO.
>> IT'S PETE AND PDD.
♪ ANOTHER DAY
LET'S GO.
IN THE LIFE OF PETE ♪
♪ ANOTHER DAY
♪ JUST SITTING
IN THE LIFE OF PETE ♪
IN A COURTSIDE SEAT ♪
♪ JUST SITTING
♪ PEOPLE WANT TO
IN A COURTSIDE SEAT ♪
TAKE MY PICTURE
♪ PEOPLE WANT TO
WITH SELFIE STICKS ♪
TAKE MY PICTURE
♪ IT WINDS UP
WITH SELFIE STICKS ♪
ON PAGE SIX ♪
♪ IT WINDS UP
♪ IT'S NEVER ENDING
ON PAGE SIX ♪
EVERYDAY, I'M TRENDING ♪
♪ IT'S NEVER ENDING
♪ PEOPLE WANT TO SEE
EVERYDAY, I'M TRENDING ♪
THE TEXTS THAT I'M SENDING ♪
♪ PEOPLE WANT TO SEE
♪ ALL MY FRIENDS ARE
THE TEXTS THAT I'M SENDING ♪
COOL AND FAMOUS ♪
♪ ALL MY FRIENDS ARE
♪ EXCEPT THESE
COOL AND FAMOUS ♪
THREE SAD VIRGINS ♪
♪ EXCEPT THESE
♪ THREE SAD VIRGINS
THREE SAD VIRGINS ♪
WHAT ♪
♪ THREE SAD VIRGINS
WHOAH ♪
WHAT ♪
♪ THREE SAD VIRGINS
WHOAH ♪
>> ALL RIGHT, CAN WE TIME OUT
FOR A SECOND?
>> YEAH.
>> WHAT'S GOING ON, GUYS?
YOU HAVING FUN?
>> I'M HAVING A BLAST.
QUICK QUESTION.
IS THIS ABOUT US?
>> WHICH PART?
>> I GUESS THE THREE SAD VIRGINS
PART.
>> YEAH.
>> BECAUSE, LIKE, WE HAVE HAD
SEX.
MAYBE NOT SUPER RECENTLY, BUT --
>> GUYS, IT'S JUST A PARODY
VIDEO.
YOU GUYS ARE JUST PLAYING
CHARACTERS.
>> CHARACTERS.
>> OH.
>> SO, PEOPLE WON'T THINK IT'S
US.
>> OF COURSE.
>> NOT ABOUT YOU AT ALL.
♪ THEIR NAMES ARE
MARTIN, BEN AND JOHN ♪
>> OH, COME ON!
♪ AND THEY WORK
ON THE SHOW I'M ON ♪
♪ THEY JUST DON'T HAVE
ANY SWAG ♪
>> WHAT?
♪ THEY'RE TALL AND WEIRD
AND SAD ♪
♪ JOHN'S WILD
BUT NOT VERY SMART ♪
♪ BUT BEN'S BREATH KIND OF
SMELLS LIKE A FART ♪
♪ AND MARTIN'S PENIS TIP
IS WAY TOO RED ♪
♪ AT THAT'S WHAT
HIS DOCTOR SAID ♪
♪ THREE SAD VIRGINS
WHAT ♪
>> HE'S TALKING ABOUT US.
♪ THREE SAD VIRGINS
WHOAH ♪
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> OH, THAT WAS MY REAL DOCTOR.
>> WE GOT TO SAY SOMETHING TO
HIM.
>> YEAH, YOU SHOULD.
>> YEAH.
>> PETE?
>> WHAT'S UP?
>> WE LOVE IT.
>> LOVE IT.
>> I JUST HAD ONE, LIKE, TINY
THOUGHT.
>> THIS GUY HAS NOTES?
LEAVE IT AS-IS.
IT'S ROCKIN' DUDE.
>> DO YOU HAVE AN ASH TRAY BY
ANY CHANCE?
>> OH, YEAH.
>> MY ONLY THING, IS MAYBE IT
COULD JUST BE LIKE COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT.
>> OH, OKAY.
>> MAYBE IT'S SOMETHING TOPICAL.
LIKE "DUNE" IS A BIG MOVIE.
YOU KNOW, SOMETHING WITH "DUNE."
>> A "DUNE" RAP.
>> ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS, IT'S NOW A
"DUNE" RAP.
SO LET'S GET SOME [ BLEEP ] SAND
IN HERE.
>> YEAH.
>> ALL RIGHT.
♪ THE PLANET DUNE
IS VERY NICE ♪
♪ IT'S A WORLD
THAT'S MADE OF SPICE ♪
♪ IT'S SANDY LIKE A PLAYA
I'M GONNA DIE-YA ♪
♪ I'M GONNA TO RIDE A WORM
AND THESE GUYS SUCK ♪
♪ THREE SAD VIRGINS
WHAT ♪
♪ THREE SAD VIRGINS ON DUNE ♪
>> WHY IS HE HUMILIATING US?
>> BEN, WHY ARE YOU DRESSED AS
WENDY FROM WENDY'S?
>> PETE MADE ME DO IT.
>> AND WHY ARE WE UP HERE?
>> HE SAID WE'RE LIKE THE FLYING
SAD SACKS.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE CAN'T STAND FOR THIS.
>> YEAH!
>> I'M GETTING DOWN.
>> ARE YOU GUYS READY TO GO
AGAIN?
>> WE CAN'T DO THIS ANYMORE.
OKAY?
IT'S HUMILIATING.
>> DAMN, GUYS.
I'M SORRY.
I THOUGHT THIS WOULD BE A FUN
THING FOR ALL OF US.
IF IT'S NOT, THEN, LET'S JUST
END IT.
>> THANKS, PETE.
>> THANK YOU, PETE.
>> I MEAN, AFTER WE DO THE
BRIDGE.
>> WAIT, WHAT BRIDGE?
>> HEY, PETE.
>> OH, HEY, TAYLOR.
>> NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
♪ BEN IS LIKE
A SAD RON WEASELY ♪
♪ HE LOOKS LIKE IF BIG BIRD
LOST ALL HIS FEATHERS ♪
♪ AND MARTIN HAS THE CHARM
AND THE SEX APPEAL
OF A SCARECROW ♪
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
♪ JOHN HAS A BIG-ASS
BOWLING BALL HEAD ♪
♪ HOW DOES HE STAY UPRIGHT
WITH THAT BIG, FAT MELON ♪
♪ AND NONE OF THEM
HAVE THE GUTS ♪
♪ TO TAKE THEIR SHIRTS OFF
IN FRONT OF A GIRL ♪
>> YEAH, THAT'S ACCURATE.
>> TRUE.
♪ THREE SAD VIRGINS
WHAT ♪
WHOAH ♪
♪ THREE SAD VIRGINS
THREE SAD VIRGINS
WHOAH ♪
WHAT ♪
THREE SAD VIRGINS
♪ THREE SAD VIRGINS
WHAT ♪
WHOAH ♪
♪ THREE SAD VIRGINS
THREE SAD VIRGINS
WHOAH ♪
♪ AND THEY'RE GONNA
THREE SAD VIRGINS
DIE ALONE ♪♪
♪ AND THEY'RE GONNA
♪♪